and to see both of you I want to start
with congrats on the movie thank you for
making me laugh and thank you for the
amount of blood that you included in the
movie we tried for more but they just
wouldn't let us so I have a ridiculous
amount of questions but I want to start
sure with the other things up first and
just get that out of the way
um did they did Amazon ever tell you how
tomorrow Ward did uh yeah yeah yeah it's
still doing really well actually which
is really strange I mean how'd you get
them to tell you yeah yeah they yeah I
have no idea how invincible's doing that
yeah they really yeah the movie's still
doing really well actually I wonder if
it's also connected with his TV show
yeah people watch both yeah absolutely
um
speaking of Amazon
um when am I going to find out the
release date of invincible season two
not today
how is it going it's going great it's
going great I mean you know I'm seeing
full animation now and we're getting
music and stuff put into it and it's
it's coming along really great and I
can't wait for people to finally see it
so that they'll stop asking me about it
uh how far along are you on season three
I can't say
far enough along that there won't be a
similar gap between season two and
season three this this is the pain this
area right now is the pain for
invincible fans so once we're through
this once season two comes out hopefully
it should be smooth sailing from from
there on so there won't be these big
large gaps uh theoretically so it's like
every year you're hoping to have a
season I don't know about that but we'll
see we'll see we're still don't nail me
down on this stuff right brinfield is
going to be excellent now jumping into
red pill that's what I got I got to
start with that because otherwise I'll
run out of time at the end um I'm so
curious well first of all when you
showed the movie to the MPAA did they
ask for any Cuts or because it's blood
they're like whatever you want to do
they didn't ask for any Cuts I mean they
wanted to have some specific wording
along with the R rating a little in the
little you know block they wanted some
warnings about Gore and blood and things
like that but no they
and when I you know tried to adjust a
few of those words they were like they
were pretty firm so you kind of tell
like we're pushing it a little bit uh
but yeah they didn't ask for any cuts
and they were they you know they seem to
like the movie Robert from what you came
up with because this is your idea to
what people see on the screen was this
what you envisioned or how much changed
because of Chris and your screenwriter
and Etc I mean there are certain
elements here and there that kind of
survived through the treatment and the
script process and the directing and
everything like a couple of you know
Renfield bringing bodies into a dark
layer and uh some of the elements of the
apartment fight I think were in the
original treatment but you know working
with Ryan Ridley and having him take
what I had written and kind of expand it
into a script there's a lot of things
that I wrote in the treatment that are
like thematically present or like he's
grown them into different things and and
that was a really fun process to be able
to see him come in and take what I had
done and and kind of expand it and then
see Chris come in and take what Ryan had
done and and transform it and and it's
been a really cool Evolution to get us
all the way to you know hold Aquafina
and cage just absolutely kicking ass on
screen it's been really cool can I tell
you one image though from the from the
treatment that I really wish we had
gotten in the movie that sticks with me
literally to this yeah please remind me
because you've forgotten
is there's this moment where it's meant
to be in the very beginning of the movie
that that the vampires are vampire
Hunters are attacking uh Dracula's
castle and Dracula comes into Renfield
instead of instead of going to let you
know the telepathy to he comes in the
door to renfield's bedroom to wake
Renfield up and while Drago's having a
normal conversation about I need you to
do this right field that there's a
there's a vampire hunter just
continuously stabbing Dracula in the
back the entire during the entire entire
normal conversation which I thought was
such a funny why'd you lose that I know
I wish we'd done it that was one of my
favorite images uh in case there's a
sequel I now know what we'll share in
the movie yeah yeah
um I love Nick Cage as Dracula he is
fantastic obviously he helps Elevate
everything because it's Nick Cage for
both of you uh what did you drink when
he said he was going to do the movie
like what was your impression to
yourself because it's a big deal
yeah uh yeah he he's amazing uh as
Dracula and he brought a lot of
vulnerability you know besides the humor
I got to stop you what did you drink
that oh what did I drink
um what did you celebrate that's a
really big deal I drank three
cheeseburgers I was so excited
yeah I think I I think I had chicken for
the Masala which is something yeah I
didn't mean to interrupt you with you no
no no no no I mean like he's so good in
it like and as a director you know
you're gonna get a great performance
because it's Nick age yeah yeah I mean
he's one of the greatest living actors
like ever
um you know you can't list the stunning
memorable like impressive amazing
performances that he's done over the
years and and
um being able to work with him you see
why he has such longevity and why he's
been in so many like amazing projects
um he's a movie fan I mean he's a movie
fan he's a horror movie fan he's
enthusiastic about the filmmaking
process he loves acting he loves being
on set he loves creating characters he
loves creating these worlds and things
like that so he's he is the same person
uh that he is now as when he was a kid
when he was making Super 8 movies with
his cousins and his friends he's that
enthusiastic about his like I work for
one year I'm jaded
Nicholas Cage he cares yeah uh I love
the recreation of the Dracula and
putting that in this movie what was it
like on set recreating those scenes and
I read and I could be wrong that you had
more of it that didn't end up in the
Final Cut yeah I mean the look I could
have made I could have I could have made
that that scene going for 10 minutes
long and go through the history of all
Dracula movies go to the Hammer movies
and everything else
um yeah we it was a lot of fun because
you know I mean obviously there's a
technical you're sort of trying to match
these lenses so there's so you really
have to kind of get nerdy about how they
originally shot those movies so that it
feels so when you're compositing cage
and Holt into these scenes you have to
match up everything you know like I said
from the lenses for the lighting and you
really gotta just really and
unfortunately we have Jamie price as our
visual effects yeah supervisor who
spearheaded all of that stuff and
figured out exactly how to shoot that so
it lined up perfectly and for me as a
movie you know lover and a movie fan and
to be able to
uh put our Dracula and our Renfield in
those movies I mean that was like a
dream come true for me personally yeah I
mean seeing those for the first time
that's why I was like oh like we really
have something special here you know
like this there's like a a a legacy
that's being paid tribute to in those
scenes that really gives the whole movie
A a level of Gravitas that I don't think
it would otherwise have in the recent
trailer and I think the first trailer I
noticed a few shots that are not in the
finished film so I am curious uh if now
I know we're talking about theatrical
release but uh I am curious if down the
road like on a Blu-ray there could be
some deleted scenes there will be yeah
and the Blu-ray there will be some
deleted scenes the the dance sequence
was a scene that we cut uh unfortunately
uh that that hold did an amazing job and
Cat Burns our choreographer did an
incredible job uh but that's the scene
that's cut and that's going to be
heavily featured in the deleted scenes
among other among other things Ben all
of Ben Schwartz's improvs will probably
make it into the scene with the creature
from Black Lagoon was cut that's just
you know there's a lot there's a lot one
of the things things that I really enjoy
is how it balances the comedy and the
horror and the blood and making you feel
like
um because Nick is doing some Twisted
things but then the audience is still
rooting for him Yeah you sort of talk
about balancing that tone making sure
you're not going too far in one and you
know what I mean yeah it starts with the
kiring Nick Holt you know what I mean it
starts with somebody who can do who can
who is unafraid to go to the places like
he does in Warm Bodies that he does in
Fury Road and things like that he's
unafraid to be weird and unafraid to eat
bugs and unafraid to look not appealing
he's he's good at playing possibly
unlikable people but he brings a lot of
charm to it and when you look into his
eyes because his eyes just bring you in
and there's so much vulnerability there
that you just you can't help but root
for him he's just he's a really truly I
mean just like just watching him on set
he really is truly an incredible actor
and I think it kind of just starts there
with just casting something like that
because
there wasn't anybody else on my list as
far as who could play Renfield when you
read this script it's got to be Nick
hold and it's got to be Nick Cage one of
the things I was curious about and maybe
maybe I missed it in the movie I'm just
going to throw it out there but you
obviously touch on you know renfeld had
a wife and a kid
um and I don't believe you explore in
the film what happened to them was that
something that was in the script or
something that you shot or that was just
like a thing that you might want to
explore down the road if you get to do
more there's there was a little bit a
tiny bit more of what we shot and in the
script that we ended up cutting out
about the backstory uh but I think that
you know I mean I you know yes in future
you know if you know if the movie does
well they want to make other movies I'm
sure that you know we'll be exploring
that the sequel focuses on Renfield and
his 90 year old daughter and they go on
a road trip on that note in a flying car
on that note I'm going to say uh
congrats on the movie I sincerely hope
it's a huge hit uh you know what we do
too right exactly